très bien mes chers collègues nous
achevons nos travaux de la semaine et
nous recevons toujours en direct sur le
site de l'Assemblée nationale madame
Claire et dont Défenseur des droits
ainsi que la délégation qui l'accompagne
madame Kaby adjointe en charge de la
déontologie dans le domaine de la
sécurité monsieur narbet chef du pôle
déontologie de la sécurité ainsi que
madame de Saint-Martin donc conseillère
parlementaire
un questionnaire vous a appris
préalablement été transmis par notre
rapporteur monsieur Boudier
il nous serait agréable de pouvoir
obtenir dans un second temps réponse
écrite à ce questionnaire nous n'avons
pas vocation en cours de cette audition
de je dirais de d'avoir une vision
exhaustive de ces questions mais nous
mettrons la focale sur sur quelques
points comme vous le savez sans doute
nous poursuivons deux objectifs à
l'occasion de nos travaux d'une part
nous cherchons à mieux identifier les
groupuscules auteur de violence qui AG
se manifestation d'autre part et c'est
la raison de la convocation qui vous a
été adressée nous examinons le
déroulement de ces manifestations pour
apprécier la conciliation opérée
évidemment entre deux objectifs qui ne
sont pas toujours faciles à concilier le
maintien de l'ordre d'une part et la
protection des droits fondamentaux des
citoyens d'autre part vous avez pour
mission constitutionnelle je vous permet
de d'insister sur le fait que c'est une
garantie importante de défendre les
droits des citoyens contre les excès que
peut commettre l'État et
c'est évidemment un rôle essentiel vous
êtes aussi en charge du respect de la
déontologie des professionnels de la
sécurité notamment des policiers et des
gendarmes vous pourrez donc nous faire
part des situations dont vous avez été
saisies évidemment sans aller sur sur le
registre judiciaire qui
évidemment peu comporter quelques
nécessités je dirais de de
confidentialité et des conclusions que
vous pouvez en tirer je précise pour
être tout à fait complet que nous avons
déjà accueilli les observations du
contrôle général des lieux de privation
de liberté et c'est pour chaque qui nous
semblait aussi intéressant de pouvoir
les compléter avec vos contributions
madame la Défenseur des droits donc
avant de vous faire prêter serment il me
revient d'ouvrir les débats donc permet
de le faire en posant deux questions
la première vous avez reçu au cours du
printemps dernier un grand nombre de
réclamations plus d'une centaine tenant
au comportement des forces de l'ordre au
cours des manifestations
quels sont les comportements qui sont le
plus fréquemment dénoncé dans ces
réclamations et relève-t-il selon
[Musique]
en novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires françaises je vais vous
demander de prêter serment donc de dire
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité pris de effectivement de brancher
votre micro comme vous venez de le faire
à l'instant de lever la main droite et
de dire je le jure je le jure je vous en
remercie si vous pouvez débrancher le
micro passer la parole à Madame Kaby
je vous en remercie là aussi
monsieur narbais je le jure merci
beaucoup Monsieur et Madame de
Saint-Martin
je vous en remercie donc je vais déjà
vous passer la parole ensuite je
passerai la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur et puis ensuite évidemment à
celles et ceux qui membres de cette
commission d'enquête souhaite pouvoir
s'exprimer donc je vous en prie
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés merci d'abord de m'avoir invité
à intervenir dans le cadre de votre
commission d'enquête je vais
effectivement répondre dans ce propos
introductif d'ailleurs à vos deux
questions et il y en aura d'autres
d'autres après on vous enverra
évidemment une contribution écrite à
l'ensemble des questions que vous avez
posées vous avez rappelé le rôle du
Défenseur des droits c'est vrai que je
préfère démarrer par ça en disant bien
que nous avons deux missions principales
la première c'est traiter les
réclamations qu'on reçoit dans nos cinq
domaines de compétence et je vais y
revenir et après c'est promouvoir les
droits et les libertés c'est que
législateur a bien pensé que nous
n'étions pas là que pour traiter des
réclamations individuelles mais bien
pour en faire des conclusions et un
certain nombre de recommandations en
gros pour qu'on reçoive plus de
réclamations ou en tout cas plus plus
les mêmes et nos cinq domaines de
compétences vous l'avez dit la question
de la lutte contre les discriminations
il y a la protection des droits des
enfants des enfants protection
orientation des des des lanceurs
d'alerte nous sommes vous l'avez dit le
contrôle externe de la déontologie des
forces de sécurité et on est là aussi
sur le pour travailler sur le respect
des droits des usagers de service public
je tiens juste à vous dire que c'est
quand même 85% de nos réclamations donc
l'immense partie de de réclamation
concerne les usagers de service public
et effectivement nous sommes le seul
organe de contrôle externe indépendant
de la déontologie des professionnels de
la sécurité mais nous ne sommes pas en
position de définir là où les stratégies
de maintien de l'ordre ce n'est pas
notre rôle notre mission concerne le
respect des règles qui s'appliquent au
fonctionnaires de police et militaires
de gendarmerie notamment lors des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre et
vraiment je veux commencer par dire que
nous sommes conscients des difficultés
inhérentes à ces missions dont la
particularité et qu'elles doivent
permettre l'expression d'une liberté
celle de manifester dans l'état égarant
alors grâce aux Saisies que nous
instruisons nous sommes un observateur
privilégié des pratiques des forces de
maintien de l'ordre elles ont permis
d'abord à la CNDS la Commission
nationale de dé il s'agit de la sécurité
puis aux défenseurs des droits de
développer depuis 20 ans en fait une
fine connaissance du maintien de l'ordre
plusieurs de nos publications récentes
dans un test et je voudrais vous les
citer à la demande du président de
l'Assemblée nationale nous avions
réalisé en 2017 une étude sur les
conséquences de la doctrine et de la
pratique du maintien de l'ordre par les
forces de l'ordre au regard des règles
de déontologie puis face à la
persistante des saisines persistance des
saisines relatives à des violences ou
des atteintes aux libertés fondamentales
lors de manifestations nous avions
publié en juillet 2020 une décision
cadre portant recommandation générale
sur les pratiques de maintien de l'ordre
ensuite nous avons rendu un avis sur le
nouveau schéma de maintien de l'ordre en
novembre 2020 et enfin depuis le début
de mon mandat j'ai rendu 5 décisions
individuelles concernant des
manifestations
à travers les dossiers traités et les
nombreuses auditions réalisées nous
observons des difficultés rencontrées
par les forces de l'ordre pour exercer
leur mission de maintien de l'ordre et
les tensions qui existent dans ce
contexte entre les forces de l'ordre et
la population le socle le socle sur
lequel nous nous appuyons dans l'analyse
des faits qui sont dénoncés c'est le
code de déontologie de la police
nationale et de la gendarmerie et la
première exigence de ce code de
déontologie c'est le respect de la loi
en particulier dans les opérations
contraignantes pour l'exercice des
libertés je veux le rappeler le respect
du droit et de la déontologie est aussi
protecteur pour les gendarmes et les
policiers et ces dernières années nous
avons donc eu l'occasion de formuler de
nombreuses recommandations sur les
pratiques de maintien de l'ordre je ne
vais pas toutes les rappeler ici mais je
vais surtout m'intéresser dans ce propos
liminaire au cas qui ne me sont parvenus
sur la période à laquelle votre
commission s'intéresse en lien avec les
recommandations qui avaient déjà
auparavant été formulée par mon
institution je vous précise d'abord
qu'au regard du délai écoulé de la
nécessité vous savez aussi d'obtenir
l'autorisation de l'autorité judiciaire
pour mener des investigations dans un
grand nombre de ses affaires et des
moyens de l'institution je ne suis pas
en mesure de vous présenter aujourd'hui
les conclusions mais plutôt de mettre
uniquement en perspective les motifs des
174 réclamations reçues avec aussi mes
recommandations donc on en est très
précisément à 174 recommandations je
vais aborder 7 points le premier je
pense 164 réclamations
ce que j'ai dit recommandation
réclamation
petit détail
vous avez raison merci
avec vous là d'abord l'usage de la force
notamment celui des LBD des grenades
l'identification des agents la question
du Rio les contrôles des localisés et
les intervent les interpellations
préventives ou arbitraire la protection
des journalistes la pratique de
l'encerclement l'utilisation des drones
et enfin la désescalade donc point par
point sur l'usage de la force le recours
à la force dont l'usage des armes est
une des modalités possibles est encadrée
par le code pénal et le code de sécurité
intérieure et les saisines portant sur
un usage de la force sont les plus
nombreuses elle représente 71 saisines
sur les 174 reçus elles sont toutes en
cours d'instruction elles comprennent
l'usage de la force physique simple
l'usage des armes des lanceurs de balles
de défense ou l'usage des grenades
sur l'usage BD
nous avons recommandé vous le savez
l'interdiction de son usage en maintien
de l'ordre le schéma national de
maintien de l'ordre dans sa première
comme dans sa seconde version maintient
son emploi en manifestation il est prévu
d'intégrer or le cas de la légitime
défense le positionnement d'un
superviseur auprès du tireur de LBD au
sein des unités constituées pour évaluer
la situation d'ensemble et les
mouvements des manifestants désigner
l'objectif et s'assurer de la
compréhension des ordres par le tireur
les saisines portant sur l'usage du LBD
représente 7 saisines sur 174 et il y a
lieu là-dessus de noter une nette
différence sur l'usage du LBD par
rapport à la séquence des manifestations
gilets jaunes où nous avions reçu 46
réclamations dénonçant son utilisation
sur l'usage des grenades je suis
également attentive et préoccupée par
l'utilisation des grenades à main de
désencerclement et de la grenade
comme le révèle le rapport de l'IGPN et
de l'iggn relatif à l'emploi des
munitions en opération de maintien de
l'ordre nous sommes le seul pays
d'Europe à utiliser des munitions
explosives en opération de maintien de
l'ordre avec l'objectif de maintenir à
distance des manifestants lors d'une
manifestation le 26 mai 2016 place de la
Nation une personne a été gravement
blessée à la tête à la suite de l'usage
d'une grenade à main de désencerclement
par un fonctionnaire de police et après
notre enquête dans une décision de
juillet 2019 nous avons constaté au-delà
de la question de la responsabilité
individuelle de l'agent que l'emploi de
la grenade a eu des conséquences bien
plus graves que celles présentées dans
la documentation de formation de cette
arme et nous avions donc recommandé au
ministre de l'Intérieur de revoir la
dotation de cette arme à la suite de
cette décision et comme indiqué dans le
sMMO il est annoncé un nouveau modèle de
GMD qui serait moins vulnérant et est
également annoncé le remplacement de la
grenade Guy F4 par la grenade gm2l qui
ne contient pas d'explosifs mais dont la
moindre dangerosité est encore sujette à
caution nous serons attentifs à leur
utilisation les saisines portant sur
l'usage des grenades représente 25
saisines sur le total des réclamations
cela comprend également les grenades qui
rejettent simplement du gaz lacrymogène
deuxième point que je voulais aborder
avec vous concernant l'identification
des agents dans de nombreux dossiers que
nous traitons des fonctionnaires de
police mis en cause ne sont pas
identifiables car ils portent des
casques de moto intégraux des cagoules
en dehors de tout cadre légal au
réglementaire certains ne sont pas
porteurs de leur numéro référents
identité opérationnelle le Rio ou en
tout cas celui-ci n'est pas visible
au-delà du fait que ces pratiques ne
sont pas permise elles font obstacle
d'abord à toute communication entre
force de l'ordre et personne participant
à une manifestation et aussi ainsi qu'à
un contrôle par l'institution du
Défenseur des droits mais aussi par les
corps d'inspection et c'est ce que nous
avons rappelé dans une décision rendue
en décembre 2019 concernant un agent
ayant fait usage de la force au cours
d'une manifestation qui était cagoulée
et dont l'identification avait de ce
fait été rendu plus difficile dans une
autre affaire lors d'une manifestation
ou un fonctionnaire de police avait fait
usage de la force à l'égard d'un jeune
homme il n'avait pas pu être identifié
ni par ses collègues ni par les
autorités de la préfecture de police en
raison de son intervention en civile et
porteur d'un casque intégral dans une
décision du 24 novembre 2020 j'ai donc
rappelé la nécessité d'identification
des policiers et gendarmes afin
d'assurer un contrôle effectif de leur
déontologie le ministre de l'Intérieur
en réponse à cette recommandation a
renvoyé à la publication du schéma de
maintien de l'ordre qui rappelle
l'interdiction du port de la cagoule de
la nécessité de porter l'uniforme
pendant les opérations de maintien de
l'ordre et de l'Opéra et de l'obligation
aussi du port du Rio le Conseil d'État
vous le savez a aussi été saisi d'un
recours sur la question du non port du
Rio observé par les auteurs du recours
pendant des manifestations à l'occasion
d'un référé liberté sur ce point nous
avons déposé des observations dans le
Conseil d'État en mars 2023 nous avons
indiqué que l'identification des forces
de l'ordre est difficile dans le cadre
d'opérations de maintien de l'ordre pour
les raisons suivantes
le port du numéro d'identification à Rio
par les agents intervenants en uniforme
d'abord n'est pas systématique sur les
tenues portées par les policiers
militaires de la gendarmerie le
matricule n'est pas visible en raison du
port d'un gilet dit tactique par dessus
l'uniforme les agents intervenants
civils ne sont pas toujours porteurs du
brassard police ce qui crée des
difficultés d'identification parfois
aussi source de confusion y compris
d'ailleurs au sein des forces de l'ordre
et le recours aux enregistrements vidéo
issus des caméras de voies publiques des
caméras portées par les agents ou des
caméras appareils photos utilisés par
toute personne présente sur les lieux en
fait régulièrement le seul moyen
d'identifier les protagonistes d'une
intervention or les images enregistrées
permettent rarement de voir le numéro
RIO soit en raison de la distance soit
en raison des mouvements des personnes
susceptibles de le porter les saisines
portant sur ce problème sur des
problèmes d'identification ne peuvent
encore à ce stade être évalués elles le
seront en fonction des réponses par
l'institution aux directions générales
sur ces demandes d'identification je
vous rappelle que le Conseil d'État ne
s'est pas encore prononcé sur le fond
uniquement sur le référé et d'ailleurs
vient de nous demander de produire des
observations puisque on peut produire
des observations à la demande d'une des
parties ou à la demande du tribunal
lui-même alors l'occurrence le Conseil
d'État nous l'a demandé le troisième
point que je voulais évoquer avec vous
c'est les contrôles délocalisés et les
interpellations préventives ou
arbitraires le contrôle délocalisé
consiste à interpeller vous le savez
bien un groupe de personnes pendant une
manifestation puis elle éloignée aux
fins déclaré de procéder à des contrôles
d'identité dans un local de police par
exemple hors de tels sont illégaux quand
les conditions prévues par l'article
78-3 du code de procédure pénale ne sont
pas réunies pour procéder à une
vérification d'identité en vertu de
cette disposition ce n'est que si une
personne contrôlée refuse de justifier
son identité ou si elle est dans la
possibilité de le faire qu'elle peut
être transportée au commissariat de
police le plus proche durant le temps
strictement nécessaire à l'établissement
de son identité à plusieurs reprises
notamment dans une décision du 10
décembre 2019 le Défenseur des droits a
demandé de mettre fin à la pratique des
contrôles d'identité délocalisé sur les
interpellations préventives qui consiste
à interpeller des personnes en amont
d'une manifestation par exemple si elles
sont trouvées porteuses d'objets qui
sont considérés comme faisant obstacle à
l'action des forces de l'ordre je pense
à des masques de protection ou des
lunettes de piscine des interpellations
sont arbitraires lorsqu'elles n'ont pas
de base légale ou que le motif est
erroné sur ces pratiques d'ailleurs le
schéma de maintien de l'ordre reste muet
j'ai été saisi de réclamation dénonçant
le caractère arbitraire d'interpellation
lors des dernières manifestations je
porterais bien sûr une attention
particulière à ces interpellations et je
prendrai position à l'issue des enquêtes
notamment en interrogeant sur les
critères pour y recourir les
instructions qui ont été données par
l'encadrement et leur fondement
juridique ces pratiques
induisent clairement un risque de
recourir à des mesures privatives de
liberté de manière disproportionnée et
de favoriser aussi des tensions les
saisines portant sur ces privations de
liberté de liberté arbitraire concerne
27 réclamations
le quatrième point sur la protection des
journalistes
sur ce point des interpellations est-ce
que bon vous le savez notre commission
d'enquête et délimitée aussi dans le
temps puisque elle se terminera comme le
prévoit d'ailleurs les textes au plus
tard six mois après après la
constitution est-ce que vous serez en
mesure de nous communiquer ces éléments
avant cette date ou j'ai très peur que
non mais je vais revenir je vais revenir
à la fin il y a vraiment le temps de
l'enquête qui généralement est au-delà
et au-delà de 6 mois et je vous dirai un
peu les les circonstances parce qu'en
fait non mais si je peux d'ailleurs vous
répondre en partie là dessus en gros sur
les 174 réclamations que nous avons il y
en a un tiers qui vont être clôturés
assez rapidement avec qui sont
d'ailleurs en train d'être clôturé parce
qu'il y a pas les éléments parce que le
réclamment répond pas aux pièces
supplémentaires parce qu'en gros il y a
où il y a pas d'image on n'a pas ce
qu'il faut pour pour enquêter on en a un
cinquième qui sont concernés par
l'accord préalable procureur puisque ou
du ou du magistrat saisie au judiciaires
et il y a la moitié et qui est libre de
faire l'objet d'investigation et
d'ailleurs les investigations sont en
cours voilà mais mais honnêtement et je
me tourne vers Benoît j'ai pas tellement
de doute que ce sera au-delà de 6 mois
mais on ne vous inquiétez pas on est
dans la même urgence même urgence que
vous donc je reviens sur la question de
la protection des journalistes
inquiétait le quatrième point que je
voulais aborder avec vous et qui a
certainement été le plus critiqué à
l'occasion de la rédaction du schéma de
maintien de l'ordre le Conseil d'État
dans son arrêté du 10 juin 2021 à
censurer la condition d'accréditation
auprès des forces de l'ordre ainsi que
l'obligation de dispersion le nouveau
schéma était largement réécrit à la
suite de cette censure du Conseil d'État
et à l'issue des travaux de la
commission de la rue aussi qui avait été
créée vous savez dans la lignée du débat
sur l'article 24 de la proposition de
loi relative à la sécurité globale et
donc il y est précisé que les
journalistes peuvent circuler librement
au sein des dispositifs de sécurité qui
continuer à exercer leur mission lors de
la dispersion dans la troupements et
qu'ils sont et qu'ils ont la possibilité
de porter des équipements de protection
je vérifierai le respect de ce nouveau
cadre lors de l'examen des affaires
concernant les journalistes par ces
nouveaux c'est une nouveauté nous avons
reçu 6 réclamations si cesines de
journalistes lors des manifestations
dont nous parlons ce qui n'était pas le
cas auparavant une nouveauté pour nous
sur la pratique de l'encerclement ou de
l'engagement vous savez que cette
pratique consiste à priver plusieurs
personnes de leur liberté de se mouvoir
au sein d'une manifestation ou à
proximité immédiate de celle-ci au moyen
d'un encerclement par les forces de
l'ordre qui vise à les empêcher d'entrer
ou de sortir d'un périmètre défini le
terme de NAS est régulièrement utilisé
d'ailleurs par les médias cette pratique
ne fait pas partie des enseignements
officiels il n'a pas non plus de base
légale selon les autorités cette
technique peut être utilisée pour
procéder à des interpellations ou aux
fins d'immobilisation ou pour
immobiliser temporairement une nébuleuse
et la neutraliser dans notre la décision
4 de 9 juillet 2020 que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure nous avions réitéré notre
recommandation qu'il soit mis fin à
cette pratique il s'agit purement et
simplement d'une pratique conduisant à
priver de liberté des personnes sans
cadre juridique et une vigilance
particulière doit aussi être accordée
aux observateurs
identifiables dans sa nouvelle version
le schéma de maintien de l'ordre prévoir
que afin d'éviter le recours à des
techniques de maintien de l'ordre
pouvant présenter des risques supérieurs
d'atteinte aux personnes il peut être
recouru à l'encerclement d'un groupe de
manifestants pour prévenir ou faire
cesser des violences graves et
imminentes contre les personnes et les
biens cette encerclement doit dès que
les circonstances de l'ordre public le
permettent systématiquement ménager un
point de sortie contrôlé pour ces
personnes le recours à l'engagement à
l'engagement pardon et dès lors
maintenus dans le schéma de maintien de
l'ordre mais il doit pouvoir être
justifié pour prévenir ou faire cesser
des violences graves et imminentes
contre les personnes et les biens
l'ajout de l'obligation de l'aménagement
systématique d'une échappatoire
correspondait à une remarque de notre
part mais la rédaction retenue sur le
point de sortie contrôlée TAmbigu
puisqu'il n'est exigé que lorsque les
circonstances de l'ordre public le
permettent les saisines qui portent sur
la pratique de l'encerclement concerne
22 réclamations
sur l'usage des drones sur l'utilisation
des drones on a eu l'occasion de nous
prononcer sur l'utilisation des drones
dans un avis sur la PPL sécurité globale
et dans un avis sur le projet loi
relatif à la responsabilité pénale et à
la sécurité intérieure au cours des
années 2020 et 2021 nous l'avions dit
alors l'usage d'un tel outil
particulièrement intrusif et susceptible
de porter notamment atteinte à la
liberté de manifester faute d'un
encadrement très strict depuis vous
savez que le juge des référés du Conseil
d'État du 24 mai 2023 valider l'emploi
de drones par les forces de l'ordre
concernant le survol des cortèges du 1er
mai le Conseil d'État a rappelé qui se
prononcerait au fond sur la légalité du
décret issu de la loi sur la
responsabilité pénale et la sécurité
intérieure ultérieurement
sur la des escalade nous avions publié
en 2021 une étude des escalades de la
violence et gestion des foules
protestataires quelles articulations en
France et en Europe aujourd'hui réalisé
par une équipe une équipe de chercheurs
entre décembre 2018 et juin 2021 et
conduite avec la participation de la
police et de la gendarmerie nationale
l'étude interroge le modèle français de
maintien de l'ordre et sa vision
confrontationnelle les chercheurs
soulignent en particulier les
difficultés créées par le recours aux
forces locales de sécurité habitués aux
interpellations individuelles et
insuffisamment formés aux situations de
maintien de l'ordre visant la mise à
distance des foules les chercheurs
constatent une inadéquation se
traduisant souvent d'ailleurs par la
mise en danger des manifestants revenant
aussi sur l'enjeu du traitement
médiatique des manifestations
stratégiques pour les manifestants comme
de plus en plus pour les forces de
l'ordre l'étude fait état d'une
dangereuse tentation de face à face et
s'attarde sur la judiciarisation du
maintien de l'ordre véritable rupture de
paradigme aux multiples effets l'étude
évoque enfin le modèle belge de la
gestion des gauchers négocier de
l'espace public exemple plus abouti de
police de la facilitation qui a fait le
choix de privilégier l'accompagnement
des manifestations sur le contrôle des
foules ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y
a pas aussi des difficultés chez les
Belges je continuerai à être vigilante à
la mise en oeuvre de ces pratiques
notamment au travers des 174
réclamations individuelles que j'ai
reçues concernant la période étudiée par
votre commission j'espère que ma
présentation aura permis de contribuer
aux réflexions de votre commission pour
aboutir à un rapport et des
recommandations permettant d'atteindre à
juste équilibre entre la nécessité de
maintien de l'ordre et l'exercice de la
liberté de manifester
merci beaucoup madame merci aussi pour
cette typologie des différentes
réclamations ça permet de bien éclairer
les choses sans tarder je vais passer la
parole à Monsieur le rapporteur
merci Madame ma Défenseur des droits et
vos propos extrêmement éclairants
extrêmement utiles comme souvent
concernant votre autorité administrative
indépendante et nous avons l'occasion
régulièrement de vous écouter
et de prendre en considération quand
nous le pouvons vos propositions vos
remarques plusieurs questions
la première très directe est-ce que la
France a un problème avec ses forces de
l'ordre
selon votre point de vue oui ou non
est-ce que quels sont les modifications
du schéma national de maintien de
l'ordre que vous estimez nécessaire
voire parfois urgemment nécessaire
et puis une troisième question qui est
un peu accessoire mais pas tout à fait
il vous souvient peut-être que dans le
cadre de la locmi l'orientation de
progression du ministère c'est-à-dire la
dernière fois nous avons l'occasion de
nous voir
j'avais souhaité avec ma collègue député
Cécile tomayer d'intégrer dans le
rapport annexé la création par le
ministère de la terre d'un collège de
déontologie
indépendant serait beaucoup dire en tout
cas
présidé par une autorité indépendante et
donc pas par une autorité issue du
ministère de l'Intérieur ma question est
la suivante est-ce que vous avez été
associé ou pas à la constitution de ce
collège de déontologie
merci beaucoup je vous repasse tout de
suite la parole je commence à répondre à
vos questions et quitte à ce que au
Pauline cabillaud bonnet en arbais
complète je ne votre question vous la
posez avec oui ou non je n'y répondrai
pas en ces termes-là je pense qu'on a un
vrai travail à faire de réflexion sur ce
lien police population sur la question
de la confiance
mais je ne le formulerai pas comme ces
formuler comme vous venez le faire dans
votre question je dis pas que c'est ce
que vous dites je me doute bien mais
mais mes volontairement je ne réponds
pas en revanche je pense que c'est
vraiment important de se poser des
questions je suis absolument convaincue
que le travail que nous faisons
contribuent à la confiance que la
population peut avoir dans sa police
parce que c'est par un contrôle externe
indépendant qui dit quand il y a
justement un usage disproportionné de la
force ou quand il y a des atteintes et
un non respect de la déontologie je
pense que ça protège aussi les autres
policiers et gendarmes je pense que
c'est important de le reconnaître au
moment où il y a un certain nombre de
difficultés et je crois que ce point est
vraiment important je répète très
souvent que le contrôle de la
déontologie se fait d'abord parler les
pères ensuite par l'encadrement il y a
évidemment l'importance du contrôle
interne et je continuerai à le dire le
rôle de l'IGPN et de l'iggn le contrôle
externe est indispensable et présent
dans toutes les démocraties parce qu'il
faut un contrôle externe et indépendant
qui d'ailleurs n'a pas toujours les
moyens qui lui sont nécessaires pour
faire pour mener à bien le travail
sur la question de la modification du
schéma de maintien de l'heure je l'avais
dit en fait on avait on avait vraiment
rendu un avis et on avait là-dessus
échangé d'ailleurs avec la ministre de
l'Intérieur de façon assez constructive
à ce moment-là il y a un certain nombre
de nos recommandations qui ont été
suivies qui sont dans le schéma de
maintien de l'ordre sur le port
obligatoire du Rio sur l'interdiction du
port de la cagoule sur la communication
la question je passe toujours sur qu'il
soit complètement appliqué et donc même
dans ce qu'il y a dedans qui nous paraît
dans le bon sens ce n'est pas toujours
ce n'est pas toujours respecté après il
y a certaines de recommandations qui
n'ont pas été suivies dont celles de ne
pas utiliser ni les LBD ni les grenades
je vous redis qu'on est le seul pays
d'Europe à les utiliser et si nous
disons ça c'est parce que nous avons vu
trop trop d'accidents et de blessés avec
l'utilisation de ces armes de de force
de force intermédiaire
donc voilà je je vous redis qu'il y a
des points qui avancent dans ce schéma
de maintien de l'ordre mais qui
effectivement faudrait aller plus loin
sur le collège de déontologie issu de la
loopmie la réponse à votre question il a
été créé mais nous n'avons pas été il
avait été créé mais en tout cas on n'est
pas enfin il a pas été créé on n'est pas
associé il est en cours on n'a pas été
contacté enfin à moins que non
si vous me permettez non et ceci dit
c'est le collège déontologie du
ministère de l'Intérieur et c'est vrai
qu'en tant qu'autorité administrative
indépendante il est difficile d'être on
peut on discute régulièrement avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur notamment sur
le snmmo on a été consulté mais voilà
c'est on peut difficilement en être
humain et les du tout prévu qu'on en
soit membre
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
d'autres questions je me tourne vers les
membres de la commission y a-t-il
d'autres alors moi j'avais un point qui
qui me semblait
sur sur ce que vous évoquez notamment
les les grenades glie F4 donc sous votre
contrôle
hier nous avions l'audition de Monsieur
Castaner qui nous indiquait que il avait
pris la décision suite justement à ces
rapports qui avaient été réalisés à ce
que ces grenades soient écartées du
maintien de l'ordre et il nous indiquait
que 80
000 d'entre elles qui étaient en stock
avait été détruite donc donc vous
confirmez cette
ça je peux pas vous confirmer si elles
ont été détruites et c'est encore trop
tôt pour savoir dans les réclamations
qu'on a si elles ont pu être utilisées
ou pas mais ce qui est sûr ce qui nous a
tout de suite frappé c'est la baisse du
nombre de blessés dû à l'usage plus
général de l'ensemble de ces quelque
chose qui nous a frappé mais dès le
début voilà et on a on a bien vu que les
consignes avaient été de les utiliser
moins
quant à la question de l'identification
des des agents c'est vrai que le pour y
parvenir l'outil c'est le rio par contre
il y a un endroit où je vois une
difficulté vous l'évoquez dans l'un des
cas que vous mentionnez c'est le
policier en civil est-ce que le policier
en civil dès lors qu'il a le rio il
n'est plus en civil quoi et donc est-ce
que vous avez une solution par rapport à
cela ou des préconisations ce que on
voit bien que ça peut être une
difficulté technique j'entends moi je
peux juste vous parler de la situation
c'était une des premières décisions
qu'on a rendu quand je suis arrivée dans
lequel j'ai quand même été étonné suite
aux lois travail c'est un jeune qui est
mis à terre et maîtrisé et sur lequel un
policier continue de frapper donc c'est
vraiment l'usage disproportionné de la
force à partir du moment où il est
maintenu voilà et donc et donc on
cherche à savoir qui c'est il est en
civil aucun de ses collègues autour ne
sait qui sait son encadrement ne sait
pas qui c'est
ça c'est absolument enfin en termes de
confiance qui était première question en
termes de confiance dans la police c'est
excessivement délétère donc ce qui ne
nous paraît pas possible je peux
comprendre le principe du policier en
civil je suis pas naïve et je peux je
peux je peux comprendre un certain
nombre de choses sauf que quand il est
quand il lui fait usage de la force et
qu'il n'est pas reconnaissable et que
cet usage est disproportionné non
nécessaire ça pose quand même réellement
un problème voilà
oui la question la question du brassard
police mais il était bien si il a le
brassard politique identifiable on est
bien d'accord je vois bien votre
question
très bien monsieur Caron je vous en prie
merci monsieur le président
merci Madame la Défenseur des droits
vous avez fait état dans vos propos de
nombreuses pratiques illégales de la
part des forces de l'ordre contre des
manifestants dans un passé récent vous
aviez déjà exprimé le fait d'avoir été
choqué par les images de
répression de ces manifestants vous avez
dit avoir été choqué je cite par des
propos totalement inadmissibles de la
part de membres des forces de l'ordre
j'avais parlé d'agents qui ne respectent
ni la loi ni la déontologie j'ai donc
deux questions je serai bref aujourd'hui
premièrement
je vous en prie selon vous l'état a-t-il
une responsabilité dans les violences
constatées en manifestation
deuxièmement la démocratie s'exprime
notamment par la liberté de manifester
on considérant les éléments dont vous
avez connaissance le droit de manifester
en France est-il aujourd'hui à moindry
et menacé ce qui aurait donc pour effet
que la démocratie en France serait à
moindrie et menacé merci
[Musique]
ça nous a pas échappé que j'ai quand
même beaucoup utilisé les conditionnel
par rapport aux réclamations que nous
avons en ce moment c'est-à-dire vraiment
je veux être prudente il va nous falloir
on est plutôt nous à penser de l'ordre
d'un an pour rendre des décisions il y
aura la fois des décisions individuelles
épines décisions cadre sur justement ce
que nous avons observé comme ça a été
fait à l'époque pour les gilets jaunes
et d'en tirer un certain nombre de
conclusion donc je pense honnêtement là
que c'est trop tôt pour dire et c'est
bien pour ça que j'ai que j'ai utilisé
le conditionnel il est vrai vous faites
référence à un communiqué de presse
qu'on a fait au moment où nous avons vu
un certain nombre de vidéos qui
manifestement elle n'a pas forcément
obligé là d'utiliser le conditionnel
quand une personne sans domicile place
de la Bastille se fait insulter la vidéo
le montrant je me suis quand même
capable là de le voir et d'ailleurs je
vous signale qu'on s'est auto saisi de
cette situation puisqu'on pense bien
qu'on a affaire à une personne qui ne
nous connaît pas forcément et qui ne
penseraient pas à nous saisir et qui est
particulièrement et particulièrement
vulnérable la question de de la
responsabilité de l'État posé comme ça
je réponds pas par oui ou par non la
réponse elle est elle est plus affinée
que ça il y a une responsabilité de
l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre à
reconnaître quand il y a eu un usage de
la force disproportionnée quand les
propos qui ont été tenus ne sont pas
respectueux du code de déontologie c'est
ça qu'il faut signaler et nous ce que
nous allons observer et c'est là qu'on
est vraiment utile en complément de la
justice on sent très bien qu'à certains
moments il y a une mauvaise
compréhension du fait que la justice est
déjà saisi l'affaire pourquoi vous vous
y mettez par exemple quand on sait auto
saisie tout récemment mais parce que
nous nous allons aller chercher et
observer quel a été la formation de ces
forces de l'ordre mises en cause quel
est l'encadrement quels ont été les
communications explications sur ce qu'il
devait faire et nous allons nous
intéresser à toute cette partie là qui
nous paraît aussi très importante et
donc qui revient aussi à la question du
systémique que vous pouviez poser mais
qui dit comme ça peut heurter ce qui
nous intéresse juste c'est qu'est-ce qui
dans l'organisation peut générer
justement c'est ces propos ou ses actes
qui sont contraires à la déontologie des
forces de sécurité et après sur la
question essentielle de la liberté de
manifester vraiment je le premier
objectif du schéma du maintien de
l'ordre c'est ce respect de la liberté
de manifester c'est le premier objectif
c'est notre objectif démocratique et
vous avez raison de dire que c'est un
des éléments de la démocratie la
démocratie c'est pas simplement le vote
c'est aussi la liberté et associative je
sais que vous en avez parlé juste avant
et la liberté de de manifester et
effectivement si nous nous prononçons
sur ces sur ces questions là c'est bien
parce que nous cherchons à observer
justement si cette liberté de manifester
peut être à Moinerie par les risques que
peuvent prendre les manifestants puisque
le premier objectif du maintien de
l'ordre c'est la liberté de manifester
et c'est de le respect de l'INT de
l'intégrité physique à la fois des
manifestants mais aussi des des forces
de l'ordre c'est bien les deux objectifs
honnêtement pour l'épisode qui vient de
se passer c'est trop tôt pour répondre
directement à votre question et je suis
désolé je sens bien que le temps de
l'enquête n'est pas le temps à la fois
de votre commission et le temps
médiatique mais je pense que les
résultats restent tant mieux non mais le
sérieux de notre travail c'est parce que
justement nous menons des enquêtes en
contradictoires nous allons demander des
pièces nous allons auditionner les
parties prenantes
monsieur le rapporteur
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
cette gentillesse vous au nord et
n'étonne pas de vous
non très sérieusement
vous avez raison Madame la Défenseur des
droits d'être prudente évidemment sur
les cas les plus récents qui sont dans
l'instruction est encore en cours mais
vous en avez
documenté d'autres vous avez enquêté sur
d'autres cas alors je vais peut-être
élargir le cadre de ma question est-ce
que si vous prenez du recul sur la
question des manifestations en France et
qu'on se projette donc deux trois ans en
arrière sur un certain nombre de cas que
vous avez pu étudier sur lesquels vous
avez réellement enquêté
vous avez pu constater je vais vous
poser la même question cette fois-là
qu'il y avait une vraie responsabilité
de l'État dans l'escalade de la violence
et est-ce que vous avez pu également
constater que vous aviez le sentiment
que le droit de manifester aujourd'hui
n'était pas garantie comme il devrait
l'être pour tous les citoyens
ce que nous observons c'est une peur de
manifester chez certaines personnes par
rapport au risque justement physique et
la question de la protection physique
est absolument essentielle je ne nie pas
la complexité de la question parce que
la partie des black-box ne m'a pas
échappé est excessivement compliqué à
gérer donc cette question elle est
absolument essentielle elle est
multifactorielle et donc je ne répond
pas de façon de façon simpliste qui est
sûr c'est qu'on a vu une augmentation
des violences à certains moments qui
n'étaient pas nécessaire et
proportionnés de la part des forces de
l'ordre d'abord dans les lois de travail
après dans les dans les gilets jaunes et
qui est lié à plusieurs facteurs c'est
bien pour ça que je vous ai énuméré tout
ce que nous pouvons observer dont
l'utilisation
des armes de force intermédiaire sur
lequel le risque est important et que
nous tenons à rappeler et à redire que
dans les autres pays d'Europe ce n'est
pas utilisé et pour et pour de bonnes
raisons parce que les risques sont trop
importants et et oui on observe un
certain nombre de personnes qui nous
disent avoir peur de manifester à cause
des risques pour leur intérêts physiques
c'est une responsabilité absolument de
l'état de permettre la liberté de
manifester et donc dans des conditions
dans des conditions correct mais c'est
multifactoriel
oui mais mais je ne serai pas aussi
directe sur cette liberté de manifester
ta taille il y a des un certain nombre
de petit atteintes de petites atteintes
qui effectivement pose un certain nombre
de problèmes et je redis l'importance
quand il y a des situations qui sont
inadmissibles avec un usage de la force
ni nécessaire ni proportionnée quand il
y a des propos inadmissibles c'est très
important que ce soit condamné et je
voudrais juste vous dire à ce titre là
depuis le début de mon mandat nous avons
rendu 12 décisions où nous avons demandé
des poursuites disciplinaires j'ai eu
cette réponse de la part du ministre de
l'intérieur avec quatre situations où a
été fait un rappel à la loi un rappel au
règlement si nous avions demandé des
poursuites disciplinaires c'était pas
simplement pour dire un rappel au
règlement parce que dans ces cas-là nous
le faisons nous-mêmes de dire un rappel
au règlement c'est qu'on pensait qu'il
fallait
une sanction plus importante et des
poursuites disciplinaires je pense
effectivement que c'est par ces
poursuites disciplinaires qu'on
rétablira la confiance et je pense que
ce point-là est absolument
est absolument essentiel
merci beaucoup madame Marceau
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
Edon je tiens à saluer au-delà de des
raisons de votre présence aujourd'hui
votre travail parce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de saisir entre guillemets
vos services pour des sujets et des
questions très préoccupantes de citoyens
charentés et merci de des retours de vos
services
à travers les réclamations dont vous
êtes c'est saisie et de vos de vos
investigations quel est votre
connaissance où vous l'avez un petit peu
esquissé en citant le terme de Black
Bloc quel est votre connaissance sinon
votre regard sur la
votre connaissance de la violence
justement de ces groupes muscules qui
qui souvent viennent en découdre alors
je résume très largement
pas mal de nos auditions puisque nous
étudions dans cette commission d'enquête
un peu leur histoire et je mets entre
guillemets puisque c'est comme ça que
des auteurs ou des sociologues en tous
les cas connaisseur du sujet des acteurs
parlent aussi de l'évolution dans le
temps de ces groupuscules violents que
nous étudions donc quel est votre regard
votre connaissance et qu'elle peut-être
impact ou qu'elle est-ce que c'est une
analyse une donnée d'analyse
complémentaire dans vos investigations
vous l'avez un petit peu dit je l'ai
perçu et c'est important pour nous parce
que c'est au cœur du sujet de notre
commission d'enquête merci mais en fait
si je trouve votre question est très
intéressante et rejoins celle qui m'a
été posée plusieurs fois et qui oblige à
préciser en fait les missions nous
sommes en charge du contrôle de la
déontologie des forces de sécurité
absolument pas de compétences sur pour
instruire les allégations de violence
faite contre les forces de l'ordre et
donc non en fait du coup je ne suis pas
en capacité de répondre à votre question
parce que les réponses que je fais sur
la question de la déontologie c'est bien
à partir des réclamations que nous
recevons des enquêtes que nous avons
menées c'est à partir de là qu'on arrive
à dire un certain nombre de
recommandations
comme nous ne sommes pas compétents et
c'est tout à fait normal c'est
l'autorité judiciaire qui est qui est
dans ces cas-là compétente sur des
violences faites contre les forces de
l'ordre contre des des boutiques des
locaux contre des contre des passants
c'est l'autorité judiciaire qui doit qui
fait son travail et nous ne sommes pas
compétents donc du coup je n'ai pas
d'analyse sur cette situation là
oui je vous en prie très très
mais justement ou alors pour préciser
quels sont vos types d'investigation du
coup parce qu'effectivement vous êtes
peut-être amené à
solliciter la vie de de force de l'ordre
de différents agents qui vous apportent
aussi une vision de de ce qu'ils ont
vécu d'une situation c'était dans ce
sens-là c'est
d'abord nos réclamants ils ne sont pas
identifiés comme appartenant au Black
Box et je vais vous dire moi j'ai
l'intime conviction qu'il ne nous
saisisse absolument pas parce qu'il
défie toute autorité la nôtre y compris
donc je n'ai pas de doute là-dessus sur
le fait qu'on est pas saisi par par des
par des Black Box après vous avez raison
de dire dans la façon dont nous
enquêtons et là c'est vraiment le rôle
du pôle de Benoît de Benoît Narbé
peut-être que vous pourrez compléter
c'est vraiment de demander des pièces
d'entendre les différents parties
prenantes et puis en dehors de cette
partie en quête que Benoît va compléter
nous avons et Pauline kabiladi des
échanges réguliers avec les forces de
l'ordre avec la gendarmerie avec la
police et donc c'est et une partie des
équipes du pôle de déontologie des
forces de sécurité avec Pauline cabie
sont allés par exemple à Saint-Astier
pour voir quelle était l'entraînement
des gendarmes donc nos échanges avec les
forces de l'ordre sont réguliers et
honnêtement enfin voilà et parfaitement
apaisé constructif que ce soit aussi
avec l'IGPN l'iggn nous avons des
échanges réguliers comme nous avons des
échanges réguliers avec nos homologues
en Europe et au Québec et nous avons
participé récemment à une réunion au
Conseil de l'Europe qui réunissait à la
fois force de l'ordre et contrôle
externes de la déontologie des forces de
sécurité Benoît est-ce que vous voulez
un peu compléter sur votre travail
[Musique]
ce qu'on appelle un PV d'ambiance sur
les
le contexte dans lequel les policiers le
gendarme ont décidé de faire usage de
l'engagement la façon dont ils l'ont mis
en oeuvre les personnes qui ont été
concernées si éventuellement il y a un
point de sortie ou pas et ces éléments
seront corroborés ou infirmés par les
vidéos et en tout cas permettront de
nourrir nos investigations et en
fonction donc de l'analyse qu'on pourra
faire de son ensemble de ces premiers
éléments si on considère que des
éléments laisse penser que des
manquements à la déontologie ont été
commis ou que les éléments demandés
n'apportent pas les réponses à
l'ensemble des griefs nous pourrons
convoquer les personnes ambition donc en
fonction du niveau de responsabilité le
super hiérarchique a donné les
instructions l'agent qui les a exécutés
et ensuite on procède à des auditions
au cours de laquelle on pose des
questions on rédige un procès-verbal les
questions sont mentionnées les réponses
également et ensuite on compte ces
éditions présentes tous les éléments
qu'on a réunis donc c'est à la fois un
moment qui qui va permettre d'établir
l'effet mais également de recuire des
explications donc on demande aux agents
comme l'a dit Madame la défenseur droit
la formation qu'ils ont reçu les
instructions qui ont été diffusées et
ensuite voilà on
resserre les questions sur le
l'événement en tant que tel et
l'incident et la personne est amenée du
coup à expliquer ce qu'elle a fait
comment elle l'a fait avec
quels outils elle était en capacité de
le faire et c'est seulement à l'issue de
ces investigations qu'on pourra analyser
l'ensemble de ces éléments réunis et
soit considéré qu'il n'y a pas de
manquement soit conseillé qu'il y a des
manquements et si c'est le cas alors on
rédige une autre récapitulative qui est
une sorte de prédécision dans laquelle
on présente par écrit les éléments de
nos investigations l'analyse juridique
qu'on peut en faire et la personne a un
délai pour répondre à portée
éventuellement d'autres nouveaux
éléments de fait ou notre analyse et à
l'issue enfin on rédige un projet de
décision qui est soumis à la liste de la
défenseur et droit et du collège de
déontologie de la sécurité donc
l'ensemble de ces investigations comme
je le disais sur les demandes de
conservation et de transmission de
vidéos on a eu très très régulièrement
des agents qui sont venus au siège des
défenseur et droites nous amener des
vidéos en direct ou nous les transmettre
par des liens sécurisés sur les demandes
de rapport et d'explication c'est un peu
plus long et pour le moment on attend
des réponses de la part des différentes
directions d'emploi qui ont été
sollicitées à ce stade
pourquoi ça va prendre un an et non
j'assis sur le point que nos décisions
toutes les décisions que nous rendons en
déontologie des forces de sécurité
passent devant un collège avec des
personnalités qui sont nommées par la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale le
président du Sénat la Cour de cassation
et le Conseil d'État dedans nous avons
un ancien DGPN un ancien directeur
général de la police nationale qui est
Claude Balan et nos décisions depuis que
je suis là sont prises à l'unanimité
sauf dans deux situations on a été
obligé de voter mais autrement elles
sont prises à l'unanimité je pense que
ça donne quand même une grande force à
ce que nous pouvons dire
oui mais juste justement dans et c'est
très précis je vous remercie mais est-ce
que ça vous permettra ou dans votre
expérience passée de définir le contexte
dans lequel se situe la réclamation la
situation voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est pour savoir effectivement en lien
avec ma question si vous avez quand même
du coup une connaissance sur les
agissements de de Black Blocs en fait il
faut être très clair sur ma question
est-ce que vous contextualisez
par ces vidéos et que vous pouvez
décrire au-delà de l'action évidemment
et c'est pour ça que vous êtes saisis
donc j'ai pas de sujet là dessus mais
est-ce que du coup vous avez des
éléments de contexte sur l'intervention
qui fait l'objet d'une réclamation ou
pas sur les attaques aussi que peuvent
recevoir
on a vu aussi des images même si on en a
vu sans doute moins que vous peut-être
voilà je sais ça j'allais vous répondre
oui et non c'est à dire que dans la
l'affaire je vous ai parlé auparavant
avec le rio non visible d'un jeune mis à
terre et maîtrisé la question pour moi
au moment où l'usage de la force est
fait de façon non nécessaire et
disproportionnée puisqu'il est maintenu
ça m'est égal de savoir ce qu'il a fait
avant en fait la question n'est pas là
la question est que quand une personne
est de fait maîtriser et contrôler il
n'y a plus à avoir usage de la force et
c'est excessivement délétère donc vous
voyez oui le contexte est important mais
le fait lui-même au moment où la
personne est maîtrisée est indispensable
et en disant ça je ne nie pas la fatigue
des policiers et des gendarmes des
conditions et quand on cherche à
comprendre aussi les conditions c'est
cette partie là aussi nous intéresse
mais ça ne justifie pas ça donne des
éléments de contexte ça ne justifie en
rien l'usage de la force
disproportionnée Pauline veut
complètement et oui et pour pour
compléter effectivement
indépendamment de la personnalité de du
réclamment sur lequel nous investigant
pas particulièrement notamment savoir si
c'est un black bloc ou pas ça n'empêche
il n'empêche que évidemment puisque la
question est à voir si l'usage de la
force et légitime donc s'il est s'il
rentre dans le cadre déontologie et s'il
est donc nécessaire et proportionné ça
implique bien sûr d'analyser au-delà de
du geste en lui-même
et c'est pour ça que les vidéos on
cherche au-delà des vidéos qui peuvent
nous être apportées en cherche la
totalité de la scène pour comprendre le
le contexte
le contexte c'est à dire la scène juste
avant pour apprécier le caractère
nécessaire et proportionné de l'usage de
la force qui n'est pas
nécessairement et d'emblée l'image ne
suffit pas il faut l'image de de d'un
coup par exemple ne suffit pas il faut
savoir pourquoi il était donné pour
savoir si c'était nécessaire adapter
nécessaire et proportionnée c'est
vraiment les trois conditions posées par
la loi
non non
très bien bah écoutez madame la
Défenseur des droits mesdames monsieur
merci infiniment pour
l'échange que nous venons d'avoir mes
chers collègues nous nous terminons
cette cette audition et par la même les
auditions pour cette semaine donc nous
reprenons nos auditions mardi je repris
je précise qu'exceptionnellement et pour
nous permettre d'avancer il y a des
auditions dès mardi matin voilà donc en
tout cas merci encore et je suspends
donc les travaux de ce soir merci
beaucoup